[Music]
welcome to the british council learning
hub when it comes to teaching english to
young children our priority is to turn
their curiosity into confidence that's
why we've introduced the british council
learning hub as part of their primary
plus course it's a safe and secure
online space where your child can
continue their english language learning
adventure
at home
and it's a new way for you to be
involved in their experience our team of
experts have tailor-made the activities
to suit your child's age and personal
development so that they can complete
them independently
first you'll find all the information
you need to activate your child's
account in your welcome email we have
another video to guide you through the
process if you need more help
once logged on your child will choose
the module they're working on and press
open
welcome to yummy a module from primary
plus one it's all about food
first we want to show you the features
that give parents a window into the
classroom such as
your child's magazine
you'll find it in the resources section
this is what your child will use in
class with their teacher and classmates
there is one for every module
now
let's see how you can track your child's
progress
you and your child will find the
progress dashboard in the about this
module section
together you can celebrate your child's
successes and encourage them with areas
for improvement
there are up to 10 activities per module
that get more challenging as your child
progresses from the play to the level up
section your child will find activities
in the first two sections then songs and
videos in sections three and four
so
let's show you some activities let's
choose the do you like listening game
here your child needs to match what they
hear with the correct pictures
first they need to click on the
speakerphone icon to listen to the
narrator say whether or not they like a
certain food
do you like milk
yes i do
your child then needs to decide which of
the four pictures best matches what
they've heard
all activities open in a new tab
once your child has finished they can
close the tab by clicking on the x in
the top right hand corner
now let's try the color grouping game
designed to help your child improve
their listening and reading skills
here your child needs to group words
associated with certain meal times
by clicking on the speakerphone icon
your child will listen to the narrator
say during which meal time they eat
certain foods
for breakfast
i like cereal
your child needs to click the paintbrush
in the pink paint
then select the foods the narrator says
they eat for breakfast
they can click on the green paint to
switch colors
then paint the foods the narrator eats
for lunch
finally they press finish
songs make listening practice fun for
your child
this song is from the weather module
first your child needs to read the
sentences that are listed in the wrong
order
they can hear the song by clicking on
the play button they need to listen out
for the sentences so that they can list
them in the right order
they can also click on and read the
transcript below the video
[Music]
to complete the activity they need to
click once on the sentence they want to
move then once on the sentence they want
to replace
they can click finish to see if they
have made the correct choices
if not they can try again
like in classes our partnership with
academy award-winning animation studio
admin helps us bring english learning to
life to keep your child engaged
when your child completes their
activities they can watch a sean the
sheet video as a reward for their
efforts when your child moves up to
primary plus three they will enjoy
learning with even more stimulating
activities that they can do before and
after class this new approach will help
them feel more prepared free up more
time in class for speaking
build up their confidence and enable
them to make more progress in the
english language learning journey there
really is a lot to look forward to bye
you